what's up elimination it's Evan my one
word is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see exploded onto the
world so to help you on your journey
today I'm gonna talk about the seven
signs that you will never be rich
they're harsh but they're true so I get
a lot of entrepreneurs asking me how do
I be rich how do I make money how do I
turn this business into something
amazing and so today I'm gonna share
with you my seven signs that you will
never be rich and make sure that you are
not doing any of these if you want to
accomplish your goals sign number one is
you think you deserve it you think you
deserve to be rich you think you deserve
to have more success than you already do
you think you put in a ton of work a ton
of effort a time of energy and that
somehow now you deserve to be further
ahead in life than when you are and that
is one of the biggest mindsets that will
hold you back from ever accomplishing
the big goals that you have when you
have a sense of entitlement or when you
feel like you deserve something more
than what you have right now I'm telling
you it's a sign that's gonna keep you
where you are
you deserve the exact amount of success
that you have accomplished and even yes
even if you have things that are against
you even if you grew up in certain
environments even if you had the cards
stacked against you so what are you just
going to sit there and say well you know
that's my lot in life and never do
anything about it or are you gonna pull
yourself up and go do something about it
so if I look at my YouTube channels an
example I deserve to have 1.2 million
subscribers I put in a ton of work I
deserve to have those 1.2 but I don't
deserve to have 10 I don't deserve to
have 10 million I'm not good enough yet
if I said I'm working so hard I look at
all these people who are blowing up and
I'm putting in way more work I've done
way more videos I've been doing it for
way longer than them and they're off
crashing and I only have 1.2 million
subscribers if that was my mindset I
would lose and that's where most people
are you see people who may have put in
less work who may have had things given
to them and you feel like you deserve
to have more success and again as long
as that's your mindset you're gonna lose
because you're coming from a place of
disempowerment instead of empowerment
and so on Instagram I deserve to have
8,000 followers and I'm making better
content and if I keep investing into it
if I keep working hard at it
I will deserve to get more results and
so if you approach your situation like
to say I deserve everything that I have
in my life both from a good perspective
and from a negative and that's the place
that you start from that's a really
really healthy place where then you can
go off and become rich from sign number
two that you will never be rich is that
you always have a reason
aka an excuse you always have a reason
why you are not more successful than
where you are right now you always have
an excuse for why you aren't more rich
or why you want further ahead on your
goals and usually it's somebody else's
fault right it's your parents fault the
school systems fall to the president's
fault
it's the currency's fault there's always
somebody else to blame there's always a
reason you always have a reason why you
couldn't do it and it makes sense to you
it's a logical reason but because you
buy that reason you're never gonna hit
your goal as long as if somebody else to
blame besides yourself as long as some
person some event some system some
structure something else something else
out there besides you you write as long
as there's something else out there
besides you that you can lay the blame
on and say well that's the reason why
I'm not more successful as long as that
something else exists and guess what you
will not become successful and so if you
look at and this is what I've done this
is what I've done over and over and over
again I've studied the most successful
people in the world if you look at what
they do they take personal
accountability everything is their fault
even when it's not and when you accept
that it sucks at the beginning because
you realize that's a crappy place to be
in that everything is my fault I am NOT
further ahead because of me it's so much
better to be able to blame somebody else
right it sucks that it's your fault but
it's also incredibly empowering because
you may blame your parents of the school
system or the government or the
president whoever but you can't change
it you can't change who your parents are
right you can't change the school system
or you can't in the short term
but you could change yourself you could
change your actions you could change
your habits you can change your routine
you can change what you do on a
day-to-day basis what you do is the
easiest thing to control in your
environment and so if you take that
personal accountability to say
everything is my fault then it sucks at
the beginning but it's also extremely
liberating because you realize that if
it's my fault and I'm in control of
myself that I can change things and
that's when you start building the path
to becoming rich signed number three
then you never get rich as you stop
learning rich people learn all the time
they are constantly learning they might
be ferocious readers they might be
watching YouTube videos they might be
reading biographies they might be going
to networking events and meeting people
they might be trying to learn from the
best and whatever thing is that they're
trying to improve at they're always
learning always learning always learning
when is it enough what have you learned
everything never never never never never
never never I was working with somebody
in who wanted to become an instructor at
my dance school and he was just saying
well like I I'm a pretty good instructor
and I don't know that I need to learn to
get better like why can't it just be
enough you'll lose at everything in life
always if that is your mindset going in
if you go in thinking why can't this
just be enough my skill sets my learning
my understanding of something my
abilities I don't want to learn and get
better then you won't you will not be
rich you will not accomplish your goals
with what you have right now your skill
sets everything that you've learned
right now has gotten you to this point
if you just want to stay here great you
don't learn anything else you know how
to stay here but if you want to go from
here and get out there you're gonna have
to change what you did to get here has
to change to get out there does that
make sense
you have to acquire new skills you have
to bring in new habits you have to
surround yourself with new people you
have to change to go off and accomplish
those big goals if you don't have big
goals you don't care about hitting big
goals then fine you can complain you can
stay where you are and that might even
be a happy life for some people but if
you have big ambitions then learning has
to be a part of your daily daily daily
daily
says sign number four than you ever be
rich is that you have uninspiring goals
people have goals up don't motivate them
most people when they start off a
business especially they pick a revenue
goal right I want to hit this target I
want to have a million dollars in sales
I want to have 100k in my bank account
or I want to be a billionaire or
whatever it is that you set off to do if
money is your only goal you're gonna
fail if your only goal is to be rich
then you never will be
because being rich and making money is a
byproduct of helping others and if you
look at the most successful people in
the world you look at the richest people
in the world the people who built it
themselves I'm not talking about people
who had inherited wealth you know you
don't have a rich uncle or a rich
grandma who's gonna give you their
fortune right great so let's ignore all
those people think about the ones who've
made it themselves none of them did it
because their number one goal was to be
rich now money is important money is not
not important to that money isn't number
100 on the list but money is not number
1 on the list there has to be something
above money to you just like it has for
everybody else has gone off and
accomplished a big success and so you
have to think about your goals if money
is your only goal you will quit you will
you will give up you will not do
whatever it takes you will stop because
it just got too difficult but if you
love the thing that you're doing and you
have a goal to create something that's
never been created before you have to
will it into existence then you will
deal with the pain and you'll deal with
the struggle and you'll deal with the
ongoing crap that's involved in trying
to be a successful entrepreneur and so I
challenge you to look at your goals when
you look at your goals like I look at
mine and look at what I'm trying to do I
want to unlock you and potential I'm
trying to solve the biggest problem in
the history of the world I look at that
and it inspires me I want to wake up and
do something about it
do your goals inspire you and if they
don't then that's a fantastic
realization because you can make it
better you can come up with more
inspiring goals I don't think there's
such a thing as a just a lazy person I
just think it's a person who doesn't
have confidence and doesn't have goals
that are inspiring to them and so do a
gut check on your goals have something
I've really drives you forward a purpose
beyond just making money because that's
what the rich have
[Music]
sign number five that you won't be rich
is that you don't play nice with others
at the beginning of every
entrepreneurial career you're typically
doing everything yourself
you're everything from the CEO to the
janitor you're doing every job in the
company and it's really taxing a really
time-consuming and then somewhere along
the lines you try to hire somebody and
very often that first person you try to
hire it doesn't work out yeah because
you suck as a hiring manager you don't
know how to hire somebody and once you
do hire somebody you don't know how to
manage them properly unless you have
experience in the corporate world or
somebody else somewhere else typically
the first employee and look at it across
every company that you look up to and
respect find who their first employee
was and how long that person stayed with
the company chances are not very long
and it's not the employees fault it's
your fault because you did a bad job in
recruiting and you did bad job in
managing and so what a lot of times
happens is on terms get frustrated and
then they say well I can do it all
myself because I can or because I'm
better right because I could do it
better than them so I'm just gonna do
everything myself if you want to be rich
if you want to go far if you want to
accomplish big goals you can't do
everything yourself you have to build a
team you have to recognize that becoming
a manager ends up being the highest
leverage thing that you can do or you
have to bring on a partner who can help
you do that because as your business
grows and as you bring on more people
your contribution starts declining as a
percentage right if you have one person
it's just you then you're you're a
hundred percent contribution but if you
have 20 people working for your company
you're contributing maybe you're
contributing ten percent of the total
value or even twenty percent of the
total value because you are maybe the
most important person in the company but
still you're just providing 20 percent
of the value the other 19 people are
providing the other 80 percent and so if
the people on your team are energized
motivated doing the work that they need
to be doing growing learning pulling
their heart into their craft then your
business will never take off because at
most you're producing twenty twenty-five
percent and so if you can't play nice
with others if you can't learn how to be
a good manager how to be a good leader
how to hire well how to recruit well how
to how to maintain a sense of
camaraderie and and drive the passion
purpose home in every conversation that
you have then you'll be stuck as a lone
wolf you'll be stuck as a solopreneur
and you'll never get rich look at what
the rich do they build a team and so you
have to learn how to play nice with
others the number six sign that you will
never be rich as you think you need a
perfect plan this is the one that I
struggled with a lot in my early days as
an entrepreneur I would plan I would
plan I would plan I didn't want to make
a mistake and so I try to come up with
the perfect plan and I spent an entire
summer making a plan for my business
only to realize that once I launched a
lot of my assumptions were wrong and my
perfect plan fell apart pretty quickly
and so I think this holds back so many
people from actually getting started
with their business if you are planning
planning planning and never doing you
need to do more if you're doing doing
doing and never planning then you need
to plan a little bit more like whatever
your what if you're not naturally
gravitating towards it's probably what
you have to do a little bit more of but
for most people for entrepreneurs it's
more of the over plan the over plan the
over plan they don't take enough action
and so just recognize that you will
never have the perfect plan it's great
to have a plan it's great that
understand your market it's great to
have a pricing strategy it's great to
have a marketing strategy and operations
plan a growth plan or raising capital
plan it's great to think about these
things it's not just go out and hope
something happens hope is not a strategy
but recognize that speed is important
recognize that you don't have perfect
information recognize that as soon as
you get an idea for something you need
to go out and start testing it because
that's what's really gonna tell you you
could have the greatest plan in the
world and the greatest potential product
but if nobody wants to buy it because
your assumptions were wrong you're not
gonna get rich you're not gonna hit your
goals and so I want to help squash out
the perfectionist in you
I lost a forty million dollar deal when
I was 22 because I was too much of a
perfectionist because I didn't see that
opportunity coming because I was focused
somewhere else trying to build a perfect
plan instead of actually living in the
real world and so if you are caught up
in that zone right now thinking I need
the perfect plan eliminated from your
thinking plan spend some time doing it
and then actually get out and feel
test it to get some results and the
number seven sign that you will not be
rich is you don't have confidence this
one is a killer this one I see so many
times and entrepreneurs who have great
ideas who have great talent who are
geniuses and they just don't believe in
themselves enough they don't have the
confidence they don't think they can do
it they think Who am I to do this
because their parents in their
environment and how they grew up all
tells them that this is not what they
should be doing and it's really hard to
break free from those norms it's really
hard to do something different than
everybody in your family did or than
everybody in your community growing
updater and your culture dip it's really
really really hard and so I think a lot
of people play in that zone of wanting
to go off and be great and they admire
and Oprah they are admiring Elon Musk or
Steve Jobs or whoever it is and they
have these moments of boldness where
they feel like I could do this too and
then quickly they fall back down to
earth they fall back down to reality and
then they tell themselves that who are
they I can't do this I'm not the person
who can actually build this thing I'm
not good enough and that's where they
live 80% of their life what I try to do
with this channel is inject more belief
in the people I'm trying to inject more
confidence into you I'm trying to be a
daily resource for you to be able to use
what I'm giving you and translate that
into the positive growth for your life
and your business I think the best way
to gain confidence the best way to gain
that self belief is not gonna be by
reading a book on how to gain confidence
I don't think that helps as much I think
the best way to gain confidence is to be
around confident people and if you don't
have confident people in your immediate
environment then for me the best thing
is watching videos I've gained so much
more self belief and so much more
confidence in myself in my planes in my
vision and what I'm able to do because I
am around some of the greatest thinkers
of all time on a daily basis that's what
my channel is all about I make my videos
selfishly for myself
and I've learned from them and then I
share it with you guys and I'm so
thankful that you learn from it as well
and so I think if that's a challenge for
you if I think if you go to the spur
of I know I can do it I believe in
myself this is gonna be amazing and then
the next day you wake up and you realize
that you don't have that success or
confidence might get any more the best
thing you can do is to surround yourself
with people with videos of resources
with content that helps build your
confidence up so those are my seven
signs that you will never be rich I
would love to know what did you think
which one is most relevant most
practical most helpful most identifies
with where you're at right now
did I miss an eight nine ten that you
want to add to the list
put it down the comments below really
curious to hear from you thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one wear is if you had to
think of one word that's most important
to you or that sums you up or so it
would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details